[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen Sport hat s fost für
sie ja mit der Handball WM der Frauen
unsere großen
Themen sparen streichen kürzen die Ampel
stopft die Haushaltslöcher der CO2 Preis
steigt Subventionen fallen die
Schuldenbremse soll
bleiben was taugt der Kompromiss von
Dubai die Klimakonferenz ruft die Welt
zur Abkehr von Öl Gas und Kohle auf aber
vieles bleibt
unverbindlich und der Blick des
Künstlers auf Mensch und Natur warum das
Werk des Romantikers Kaspar David
Friedrich noch immer fasziniert eine
Ausstellung in
Hamburg das wochenlange Ring hat ein
Ende am Mittag präsentierten Kanzler
Scholz Vizekanzler habbeck und
Finanzminister Lindner ihre Einigung auf
ein Haushalt für das kommende Jahr es
fehlen ja mindestens 17 Milliarden Euro
wo nun gespart werden soll zeigt ih
Thomas
gonor um Haushaltslöcher zu stopfen soll
der CO2 Preis stärker steigen als
geplant heißt Sprit Heizöl Erdgas werden
ab Neujahr teurer bei Benzin und Diesel
geht der Literpreis wohl um etwa 4,5 C
rauf in Sachen Umwelt und Energie will
die Ampel 2024 auch am meisten sparen
knapp 13 Milliarden Euro beim Klima und
transformationsfond KTF so läuft die
Kaufprämie für E-Autos früher als
vorgesehen aus wann genau unklar kürzen
will man die
Solarförderung Streichungen
klimaschädlicher Subventionen sollen 3
Milliarden bringen für
Plastikverpackungen müssen nun
verantwortliche Hersteller eine
eu-abgabe zahlen nicht mehr der Bund
geprüft wird erstmals eine Kerosinsteuer
für
Inlandsflüge Weg sollen
Steuerbegünstigungen beim
Agrardiesel weitere 1,5 Milliarden
weniger Ausgaben verspricht man sich im
sozialen geflüchtete Ukrainer etwa
sollen nun schneller in den Arbeitsmarkt
kommen das sind also die wichtigsten
Einsparungen die Schuldenbremse soll so
2024 zunächst wieder eingehalten werden
der et kann jetzt voraussichtlich im
Januar im Bundestag beschlossen werden
und Anfang Februar in den Bundesrat über
die Einigung und die Reaktionen
berichtet Patrizia
Wiedemeier dass sie fast die ganze Nacht
durchverhandelt haben sieht man ihnen
nicht an Erleichterung dass es sie nun
endlich gibt die Einigung im
Haushaltsstreit meine wichtigste
Botschaft zu Beginn die Regierung hält
an ihren Zielen fest wir treiben den
klimaneutralen Umbau unseres Landes
kraftvoll voran wir stärken den sozialen
Zusammenhalt und wir stehen eng an der
Seite der Ukraine in ihrem
Verteidigungskampf gegen Russland klar
ist aber wir müssen mit deutlich weniger
Geld auskommen um diese Ziele zu
erreichen deutlich weniger Geld aber die
Schuldenbremse soll weiter eingehalten
werden dafür werden Gelder aus dem KTF
dem Klima und transformationsfond im
nächsten Jahr
gestrichen wir werden die Umweltprämie
also die Förderung für immobile
auslaufen lassen früher beenden sie
läuft ja eh aus aber werden das früher
tun und wir werden bei einigen
Programmen Teilen kürzen beispielsweise
bei der Solarindustrie das tut mir wie
wir setzen den Kurs der fiskalischen
Konsolidierung fort auch unter
Einbeziehung aller Sondervermögen und
nebenhaushalten stimmt der Kurs wir
haben eine Trendwende erreicht der
Kanzler habe zugesagt dass die
Orientierung an der Schuldenbremse
weiter von großer Bedeutung sei betont
der Finanzminister es klingt fast so als
habe sich hier die durchgesetzt mit
ihrer wichtigsten
Forderung eine Stunde später dann im
Bundestag klingt das schon anders Scholz
lobt in seiner Regierungserklärung die
harte konstruktive Arbeit deutet aber
schon eine mögliche Ausnahme von der
Schuldenbremse an für die Opposition
finanzpolitische trixserei sollte sich
die Situation durch russlandskrieg gegen
die Ukraine verschärfen etwa weil die
Lage an der Front sich verschlechtert
weil andere Unterstützer ih ukrainehilfe
zurückfahren weil die Bedrohung für
Deutschland Europa weiter zunimmt dann
werden wir darauf reagieren müssen es
ist eine vorhersehbare Notlage die sie
spätestens zur Mitte des Jahres erklären
werden müssen und dann wollen sie uns in
Anspruch nehmen noch einmal für die
Überschreitung der verschuldunggrenze
des Grundgesetzes diesen Trick lassen
wir Ihnen nicht
durchgehen es sind viele Details offen
es gab heftige Kritik heute die
Industrie dagegen sieht die Ampel auf
dem richtigen Weg die langfis
Transformation unser Gesellschaft auch
unserer Industrie scheint weiterhin über
die Mittel des KTF fort zu bestehen
fortgeführt zu werden das gibt
langfristige Planungssicherheit für die
die Unternehmen die Diskussion über den
Haushalt sie ist mit dem heutigen Tage
jedoch nicht beendet nächstes Jahr geht
es weiter hier im
Bundestag ist das für die Ampelkoalition
jetzt der erhoffte
Schlag man konnte zumindest heute sehr
deutlich merken auch bei Gesprächen
hinter den Kulissen dass da eine große
Erleichterung darüber herrscht dass die
Ampel es geschafft hat ihre internen
Gräben zu überwinden in dieser diesem
Haushaltsstreit damit ist eine Atempause
zumindest geschaffen für die Ampel äh
der Weg für den Haushalt
2024 ist jetzt erst einmal frei und
damit könnte auch die Haushaltssperre
die der Bundesfinanzminister verhängt
hat möglichst bald aufgehoben werden
allerdings heißt das noch lange nicht
dass dass der Druck raus ist denn wir
haben heute nur die Umrisse des
Haushalts 2024 präsentiert bekommen es
wird großen Druck geben möglichst bald
viele Details bekanntzugeben dann wird
die Ampel ganz sicher den Unmut von
Betroffenen zu spüren bekommen das haben
wir heute schon mitbekommen dass auch
bei den angedeuteten Kürzungen jetzt
sich schon Kritik
regt auch von Seiten der Betroffenen und
jeder weitere Schritt wird natürlich von
der Opposition sehr genau und sehr
kritisch beobachtet dass die Union nicht
klagt ist noch nicht ausgemacht sie wird
sich sehr genau angucken ob irgendwo
noch im Detail etwas drin steckt was
möglicherweise verfassungswiedrig sein
könnte und sie hat ja auch schon ihre
Skepsis bezüglich der Schuldenbremse im
kommenden Jahr ausgedrückt also die
Kämpfe sind noch nicht gänzlich
ausgefochten und eine ganz ruhige
Adventszeit wird es für die Ampel sicher
nicht stakun energy danke
schön und direkt nach dieser heute
Sendung gibt's noch mehr Informationen
und Erklärungen zum Thema Haushalt in
einem ZDF Spezial
Russland setzt seine Angriffe auf die
Ukraine fort in der Nacht ist Kiev
erneut mit Raketen beschossen worden
nach ukrainischen Angaben hat die
Flugabwehr alle Geschosse abgefangen
durch herabfallende tümmerteile seien
allerdings 53 Menschen verletzt worden
ukraines Präsident selenski hat in den
USA um weitere Unterstützung geworben
doch für neue Milliardenhilfen muss
Präsident beiden mit den Republikanern
verhandeln die fordern Zugeständnisse
z.B bei der US
Einwanderungspolitik nach Verlängerung
und noch einmal zehn Verhandlungen hat
es die Weltklimakonferenz in Dubai doch
geschafft die fast 200 Staaten einigten
sich auf eine Abschlusserklärung darin
festgeschrieben der Übergang weg von
fossilen Brennstoffen in den
Energiesystem und zwar in einer
gerechten geordneten und ausgewogenen
Weise kein Ausstieg wieen unter anderem
Deutschland wollte aber für viele doch
der Anfang vom Ende Elisa mbach und
makugo mit den
Details der Hammer fällt in Dubai am
Ende so schnell dass jetzt keine Zeit
mehr für Einwände bleibt das Ergebnis
zwar kein klares konsequentes aus für
Kohle Öl und Gas dafür der Aufruf sich
von den fossilen Energien wegzubewegen
bis die Welt 2050 bei Netto Null
Treibhausgasen steht klimadiplomatische
Feinheiten die Außenministerin zufrieden
diese Klimakonferenz besiegelt de facto
das Ende des fossilen
Zeitalters sicher nicht an jeder Stelle
des Textes so klar und verbindlich wie
wir uns als Europäer das an allen
Stellen gewünscht hätten
Erdölproduzenten wie Saudi-Arabien
hatten lange eine Einigung blockiert am
Ende steht ein Kompromiss mit einigen
Hintertürchen zum weiter so Gas als
Übergangstechnologie etwa oder CCS die
umstrittene Technik zur Abscheidung und
Speicherung von CO2 auf der Positivseite
die klare Aufforderung die
Energieeffizienz zu verdoppeln und den
Ausbau der erneuerbarn bis 2030 zu
verdreifachen hieraus geht ein klares
Signal an die Märkte der Weg geht nur
über erneuerbare Energien
Energieeffizienz Elektromobilität und
mit der Beschleunigung die wir in dieser
Dekade haben wird es letztlich ganz klar
zu einem Ausstieg aus den
fossilenenergieträgern führen besser
jetzt als später dies demstranten am
letzten Tag der Kop Beschlüsse sind für
Sie die eine Sache Umsetzung eine ganz
andere erst daran wird sich die Welt
messen lassen
müssen Andreas Stamm in Dubai in wie
weit wird mit der Abschlusserklärung
jetzt das Ruder herumgerissen bei der
ertabwarmmung ja es wird nicht
herumgerissen aber die
Staatengemeinschaft nimmt es fester in
die Hand beginnt zu drehen und zwar nur
noch in eine Richtung raus aus den
fossilen das ist nicht schnell genug das
wird nicht schnell genug sein um das
Ziel das große Ziel dieser
Weltklimakonferenz eben die globale
Erderwärmung auf 1,5° zu begrenzen das
zu schaffen das wird nicht gelingen
dafür gibt es zu viele Schlupflöcher
aber jedes Zehntelgrad zählt weniger
jedes Zehntelgrad weniger zählt und es
gibt mittlerweile 130 Staaten darunter
USA und China die wollen mehr die wollen
sich bewegen auch weil sich die
Erneuerbaren rechnen und weil dieser
Beschluss von Dubai Investitionen in Öl
und Gas neues Öl und Gas ja schwieriger
macht dürfte aber schwierig bleibt eben
auch wie sollen Länder ärmere Länder das
finanzieren wenn schon reiche Länder wie
Deutschland ja damit fast in einer
Haushaltskrise schlittern also es bleibt
schwierig der Weg geht in die richtige
Richtung die Weltgemeinschaft geht in
die richtige Richtung aber es sind eben
viele kleine und kleinere Schritte und
die müssen irgendwann einen großen
ergeben vielen Dank für diese
Einschätzung Andreas
Stamm Polen hat fast zi Monate nach der
Parlamentswahl ein neuen
Ministerpräsidenten Donald Tusk am
Vormittag legte er im Warschauer
Präsidentenpalast vor Präsident duda den
Amtseid ab tust steht für einen klar
proeuropäischen Kurs bereits am
Nachmittag reist er nach Brüssel wo er
morgen am EU-Gipfel teilnehmen
wird mehr als zwei Monate nach Beginn
des Krieges im Gazastreifen hat die UN
Vollversammlung in New York eine
sofortige humanitäre Waffenruhe
gefordert
153 der 193 Mitgliedstaaten stimmten
dafür zehn dagegen darunter die USA und
Israel beide argumentieren eine
Waffenruhe würde der Hamas in die Hände
spielen 23 Mitgliedstaaten enthielten
sich darunter Deutschland der Terror der
Hamas vom 7 Oktober werde in der
Resolution in keiner Form erwähnt
erläuterte das Außenministerium in
Berlin bei dem Massaker hatte die Hamas
rund 1200 Menschen in Israel ermordet
und noch immer hält sie 135 Menschen in
ihrer Gewalt die sie an dem Tag entführt
hat brutal und grausam war die Hamas bei
ihrem Angriff vorgegangen die
Erinnerungen daran lässt die
Überlebenden nicht los jennifer gürke
hat einen Deutsch Israeli begleitet der
Freunde bei dem Massaker verloren
hat der erste Besuch seit dem 7 Oktober
Meron Mendel Rei in sein Heimat Israel
um Familie und Freunden beizustehen seit
Jahrzehnten setzt sich der direkt der
Bildungsstätte Anne Frank für ein
friedliches Zusammenleben zwischen Juden
und Arabern ein daran haben auch seine
Freunde schacha und schlomi geglaubt sie
lebten in einem kibuz Nähe Gaza dort
wurden sie von der Hamas brutal
ermordet sie hatte eine besondere Freude
die sie an andere weitergab ich vermisse
sie Mutter Rahel erzog ihre Kinder zum
Frieden nach dem Tod ihrer Tochter
zweifelt
sie es reicht nicht mehr aus Frieden zu
wollen wenn man es mit jemandem zu tun
hat der Frieden grundsätzlich
ablehnt Vater Ilan will den Glauben an
eine politische Lösung nicht
aufgeben ich bin nur noch mehr davon
überzeugt dass der einzige Weg die
Zweistaatenlösung ist es kann also auch
ein Wendepunkt sein ein Besuch am grarab
rootem der Sohn von schacha und schlomi
kommt unerwartet dazu und erzählt wie
sich die Familie im Schutzraum
versteckte dann legte sich meine Mutter
auf mich ich hörte die Angreifer
allahuakbar schreien es gab Schüsse sie
warfen eine Granate
seine Eltern waren sofort tot fast eine
Stunde verharte rotem unter dem leblosen
Körper seiner Mutter ohne ihre
Aufopferung hätte der 16-Jährige nicht
überlebt für mich sind sie wahre Helden
Meron Mendel erlebt eine Heimat die
schwer verwundet ist sich aber nicht
geschlagen
gibt Rückkehr nach Israel wenn der Krieg
die Heimat zerreist die
auslandjournaldoku gibt's in der
Mediathek und hier im Programm um 0:55
uh
unter hohen Sicherheitsvorkehrungen hat
in Berlin der Prozess gegen einen
Mitarbeiter des
Bundesnachrichtendienstes und einen
Geschäftsmann begonnen der Vorwurf
schwerer landesfahrrad die Angeklagten
sollen nach Beginn des Krieges gegen die
Ukraine geheime Informationen an
Russland weitergereicht und dafür
Hunderttausende Euro bekommen haben
ihnen droht lebenslange
Haft weil er neun Menschen bei einer
Explosion in einem Ratinger Hochhaus
schwer verletzt hat muss ein 57-jähriger
deutscher lebenslänglich ins Gefängnis
wegen versuchten Mordes so das
Landgericht Düsseldorf im Mai hatte der
Mann mehrere Liter Benzin auf
Einsatzkräfte von Polizei Feuerwehr und
Rettungsdienst vor seiner Wohnungstür
geschüttet und angezündet zu seinen
Motiven machte er keine Angaben der Mann
hatte in der Wohnung wochenlang neben
der Leiche seiner Mutter
gelebt im kommenden Jahr wird öfter vom
Erschaffer dieses gemä es die Rede sein
denn der Geburtstag von Kaspar David
Friedrich RHT sich zum 250 Mal in der
Hamburger Kunsthalle wird gerade eine
Ausstellung eröffnet die nicht nur groß
sondern wirklich besonders ist Friedrich
zeigt sich dort nicht nur als Ikone der
deutschen Romantik sondern als einer der
schon früh erkannt hat wie zerbrechlich
Natur ist Martin
Niesen Wanderer über dem Nebelmeer eine
Ikone der Romantik 70 Gemälde von Kaspar
David Friedrich zeigt die Hamburger
Kunsthalle zum Jubiläum darunter weitere
Meisterwerke wie Kreidefelsen auf Rügen
oder das Eismeer dazu mehr als 100
Zeichnungen die Technik mit der
Friedrich Landschaften seiner deutschen
Heimat in Szene setzte fasziniert auch
zwei Jahrhunderte später er versteht das
wunderbar mit wenig Farben viel zu
zeigen und er beherrscht die die Farbe
die Übergänge die Lasuren die Technik
meisterhaft wie kein anderer 1774 in
Greifswald geboren studierte Friedrich
Malerei in Koppenhagen lebte und
arbeitete danach in Dresden wo er 1840
starb der Mensch als staunender
Betrachter in Rückenansicht ohne
Identität Friedrichs Blick auf die Natur
wird bis heute hunderttausendfach
kopiert in sozialen Netzwerken und der
Kunst auch solche Zitate sind Teil der
Ausstellung der Wanderer etwa als
Fotomontage das Eismeer als fragiles
Objekt menschlicher Begierde die
Romantik war die eben durchaus auch
schon kritisch auf die Natur geschaut
hat eben auch gemerkt hat man muss
aufpassen man kann die ganzen Wälder
nicht abroden das befördert Erosion und
ähnliche Prozesse sind quasi auch schon
Vordenker dessen gewesen was heute auf
uns alle hereinbricht die
Lichtstimmungen die Friedrich so
meisterhaft erzeugte wirken häufig
melancholisch als wollte er vor
Umweltzerstörung warnen und die Natur
mit dem Pinsel für die Ewigkeit
bewahren zum sportz wenn die Deutschen
Handballfrauen haben ja so h WM gespielt
ja und deswegen war der Traum vom
Halbfinale auch so realistisch doch die
schwedinen waren heute eine Nummer zu
stark schon von Beginn an mussten die
deutschen Frauen einem deutlichen
Rückstand hinterherlaufen die große
Aufholjagd blieb
aus schon früh muss Bundestrainer Markus
gaugisch eine Auszeit nehmen die
deutsche Mannschaft findet überhaupt
nicht ins Spiel klare Chancen werden
vergeben wie hier durch Berend anders
der Olympia F aus Schweden es ist ein
Spaziergang für Roberts nach 12 Minuten
steht es schon 6:0 bereits jetzt ist
klar das Erreichen des Halbfinals es
wird schwer den nur selten gelingen
solche Anspiele wie hier auf Lisa Antel
von Borussia Dortmund zum
5:12 nach der Pause zwar großer Kampf
aber auch fehlendes Spielglück dö
scheitert am bunzen am Ende heißt es 27
Z2 für Schweden eine mögliche deutsche
wmmedaille ist damit
Geschichte zum Fußball der Sieg im
letzten Gruppenspiel der Champions
League war für die Bayern ein ganz
besonderer denn mit dem 1:0 beim
einstigen fußballriesen Manchester
United haben sich die Münchner den
lifrust von der Seele
gespielt es war ein Sieg ohne Glanz und
dennoch tut er den Bayern nach der
Pleite in Frankfurt richtig gut wir
wollten hierherkmen mit mehr Power und
Leidenschaft gerade gegen den Ball das
ist uns gelungen wir waren sehr kompakt
von Beginn an fehlt es beiden Teams an
Durchschlagskraft wenn dann sind die
Bayern gefährlich der 32 Minute
unglücklich United braucht einen Sieg um
die Chance auf das Achtelfinale zu
wahren doch offensiv ist der Gastgeber
oft zu harmlos
fernanch Höhepunkt der sonst
ereignisarmen Partie der Treffer von
kingsleake command nach feiner Vorarbeit
des Torjägers vom Dienst Harry Kane
Manchester United mit der schlechtesten
Champions League Gruppenphase jemals
nicht einmal qualifiziert für die Europa
League Bayern dagegen in 40
Gruppenspielen
ungeschlagen
und alles zur Champions League ab 23:10
Uhr im ZDF also hier bei uns Jana danke
schön Sven und diese Lottozahlen wurden
heute gezogen die Gewinnzahlen lauten 10
11 22 27 31 39 Superzahl ist die 1
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
577 Regen und Schnee ist noch mal
angesagt aber es wird ruhiger mehr dazu
gleich im Wetter von östen terli das
heute journal können Sie gegen 22:40 Uhr
sehen mit Anne gellineck
[Musik]
tschüss schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter hoher Luftdruck
macht sich allmählich breit und die
Tiefs sie verabschieden sich aber noch
gibt es Regen und Schneefall vor allem
an den Alpen das in der kommenden Nacht
ja Regen und Schnee wandern allmählich
südwärts stauen sich in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen und vor allem an den
Alpen ja von Norden her da lockert es
schon mal zaghaft auf und die
Temperaturen gehen zurück auf -1°
Richtung Schleswig Holstein und 0° im
Osten es kann örtlich glatt werden in
den höheren Lagen sowies so durch Schnee
ja am mildesten bleibt es noch im
Südwesten mit 7° und mor haben wir immer
noch mit Regen und Schnee zu tun der
allmählich südwärts zieht der schneefät
in den höheren Lagen hier im Erzgebirge
und an den Alpen da setzt
Dauerschneefall ein bis Freitag und von
Norden her gibt's Auflockerungen ein
bisschen Sonnenschein ist dabei und
überwiegend trocken ist es dort bei
höchsten Temperaturen von 2 bis 9°
spürbar kühler als heute die kommenden
Tage am Freitag gibt's noch Regen und
Schnee das wird allmählich weniger bei 2
bis 8° und das Wochenende mit 2 bis 9°
milder und etwas mehr in ist dabei
schönen
Abend